[Música]
el presidente Joe biden y el portavoz de
la cámara de representantes Kevin
mccarthy llegaron a un principio de
acuerdo para aumentar el techo de la
deuda el mandatario celebró el
compromiso logrado y dijo que los
equipos negociadores finalizarán el
texto para que vaya al congreso
el jefe de la diplomacia europea Joseph
visitó Cuba y fue recibido por el
presidente Miguel Díaz canel el viaje
hace parte de la sesión del Consejo
conjunto Cuba Unión Europea que buscaba
acercar al bloque América Latina
el célebre cantante colombiano Carlos
Vives cumple 30 años de carrera musical
el artista es uno de los fieles
exponentes de la música vallenata y la
ha combinado con cumbia pop y Rock
hacemos un repaso por su recorrido
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
Estados Unidos donde el presidente Joe
biden confirmó que llegó a un principio
de acuerdo con el líder de la cámara de
representantes el republicano que hoy
mccarthy para Elevar el techo de la
deuda biden celebró el compromiso que ya
había ratificado el republicano quien
destacó que el preacuerdo contiene una
importante reducción del gasto público y
reformas para sacar a personas de la
pobreza e incorporarlas en la fuerza
laboral
acabo de hablar por teléfono con el
presidente hablé con él dos veces hoy y
después de semanas de negociaciones
Hemos llegado a un principio de acuerdo
tiene reducciones históricas en el gasto
reformas consecuentes que sacarán a la
gente de la pobreza y la incorporarán a
la fuerza laboral controlarán la
extralimitación del gobierno no hay
nuevos impuestos ni nuevos programas
gubernamentales hay mucho más dentro del
proyecto de ley
pasamos a la Habana la capital de Cuba
allí el alto representante para asuntos
exteriores de la Unión Europea josep
purrey fue recibido por el presidente
Miguel Díaz canel la visita de burrey se
desarrolla en el contexto de la sesión
del Consejo conjunto Cuba Unión Europea
que buscaría un mayor acercamiento de
Europa hacia América Latina Rafael Pérez
nos cuenta más
presidente de la república un encuentro
que puso las cartas sobre la mesa el
alto representante para asuntos
exteriores de la Unión Europea josep
burrey fue recibida en Cuba por el
presidente Miguel Díaz canel pese a las
diferencias existentes de azca en el
reconoció la importancia de los lazos
históricos y culturales entre el bloque
unitario y Cuba para favorecer el
diálogo yo creo que hay tanto en el
ámbito político diplomático como en el
ámbito de la cooperación
hay un camino que se ha ido ordenando y
que va dando resultados y creo que las
potencialidades en el futuro Son son
amplias
también opinó sobre dos temas clave en
la relación de la isla con Estados
Unidos Empezando por el embargo tengo
que esforzarme para mantener la unidad
de todos en el voto las Naciones Unidas
en contra del bloqueo tengo que
esforzarme para que todos entiendan que
incluir a Cuba en la lista de los países
que apoyan el terrorismo de una
barbaridad la reunión se dio en el de la
realización del Consejo conjunto Cuba
Unión Europea un espacio que intenta
facilitar el acercamiento de Bruselas
con América Latina en las discusiones
hurrey tocó el sensible tema de los
Derechos Humanos los derechos de las
personas derechos humanos lo que
llamamos libertades políticas que
incluyen los derechos a las
manifestaciones pacíficas la elección de
los gobiernos de forma libre y
democrática también se conversó sobre la
guerra en Ucrania Cuba mantuvo su
posición de no estar de acuerdo con la
invasión Aunque dirige la culpa a
Washington y la otan en medio de la
crisis política en Ecuador el país vivió
un incremento del 66,4% en muertes
violentas en el primer trimestre del año
según datos del Ministerio del interior
Asimismo Un aumento del 300% en
extorsiones según la fiscalía nuestro
enviado especial a Ecuador Rodrigo
cedaron nos cuenta Cómo se organizan los
ciudadanos ante estos problemas cómo me
puede ayudar William Bass antes lo paran
en busca de ayuda en el popular barrio
de chillogallo al sur de Quito es el
presidente de la Federación de barrios
una agrupación que busca organizar a los
ciudadanos ante la inseguridad estamos
tomando iniciativas como colocar las
alarmas comunitarias según datos de la
policía las muertes violentas aumentaron
en un 28% en la ciudad de Quito en todo
2022 de la desatención del gobierno
también crece la inseguridad parte de su
trabajo consiste además en reunir las
demandas de los vecinos Rosa María
Vázquez vive desde hace 30 años en el
barrio
regresar a casa cerrar bien las puertas
no no estamos estamos mal pero no solo
la falta de seguridad afecta a los
Ecuatorianos la desatención en salud
también los aqueja Gabriel orihuela es
el presidente de la asociación de
pacientes del Ecuador una ong que busca
ayudar en el acceso a medicamentos
quisiéramos no tener que hacerlo que el
sistema funcionara bien y que los
medicamentos se le entregaran a los
pacientes en la farmacias hospitalaria
qué es lo que debería suceder
orihuela atribuye la falta de
medicamentos a la corrupción y la mala
planificación del Estado tras el Kobe 19
muchas medicinales les llegan a través
de donaciones de médicos el médico nos
junta todo lo que reciben cierto tiempo
y nosotros vamos a revocar ahora tienden
a unos 1.200 pacientes por todo el país
una de ellas es Michelle realpe vive en
Quito y enferma de lupus desde hace más
de 20 años toma en torno a 10 pastillas
al día La pandemia de Kobe 19 golpeó a
su economía de clase media ahora
complementa sus ingresos elaborando
estas lámparas aquí me paso puedo
pasarme el día entero sin el apoyo de la
asociación comprar todos sus
medicamentos sería complicado yo cuando
tengo trato de no saturar la ayuda no y
le digo Gabriel y ahora sí Gabriel te
pido que me ayudes esta vez por favor
entre tanto seguirá centrada En esta
actividad que le hace olvidar su estado
de salud la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económico
dijo que los desechos globales de
plástico podrían triplicar su número
para el año
2060 una hipótesis que se intenta evitar
en París con una Cumbre internacional
sobre la eliminación de desechos
plásticos que buscará concretar un
tratado vinculante que frene la
progresión de la contaminación por este
elemento en France 24 conversamos con
Ana Lucía Maya Aguirre directora del
observatorio para la gobernanza Marino
costera de Colombia acerca de las
dificultades para alcanzar un acuerdo de
este tipo
primero mandar un mensaje esperanzador y
decir que el hecho de que ya se vaya una
segunda Ronda de negociaciones es un
paso importante a nivel internacional
digamos esta Ronda de negociaciones es
una continuación de una negociación que
se hizo el año pasado en marzo del 2022
cuando la asamblea de las Naciones
Unidas para el medio ambiente emite una
resolución Llamando a los estados para
negociar este tratado legalmente
vinculante y este año a partir del 29 de
mayo de este lunes empezamos esta
segunda Ronda de negociaciones y las
rondas de negociaciones Internacionales
hay que verlas con esperanza porque son
los pasos más importantes que dan los
estados en su conjunto hablamos de un
tratado internacional de un convenio que
vincula los estados que es obligatorio y
que va a permitir si se aprueba que los
estados garanticen la protección del
medio ambiente mediante la sustitución
eliminación y gestión sostenible del
plástico cerramos en Colombia porque el
artista Carlos Vives cumple 30 años de
carrera desde que lanzó su disco los
clásicos de la provincia el cantante
popularizó mundialmente el vallenato que
fusionó con distintos ritmos como la
cumbia el rock latino y sobre todo el
pop en conmemoración con su treintena de
años en la música era una Gira Mundial
Ramiro cuevalverena nos cuenta la
historia
el icono de la música colombiana Carlos
Vives cumple 30 años de trayectorias
desde su disco los clásicos de la
provincia una carrera que popularizó de
manera global un género nacional como el
vallenato una música de origen rural
compuesta por los sonidos del Acordeón
vives el primer artista colombiano en
ser conocido mundialmente funcionó el
vallenato con ritmos contemporáneos como
el pop el rock latino y la cumbia además
de hacer un referente para Colombia El
nacido en Santa Marta es un defensor de
la cultura latinoamericana que la música
latina Al final es nos representa como
el mundo porque es como americanos somos
una mezcla de muchas cosas no Y nuestra
música es muy diversa por eso porque
somos Europa somos África somos América
somos el norte de África en la música tú
puedes encontrar en la música latina
huellas de todos nuestros orígenes
en conmemoración por su trayectoria
vives hará una gira que recorrerá
latinoamérica nueve ciudades de Estados
Unidos y hasta llegar a Europa donde
tocará canciones de discos anteriores
explorando la cultura colombiana yo no
quiero que mi música sea para para que
nos escapemos sino para que entendamos
todo lo que somos como colombianos el
ganador de 17 Grammys Latinos y multi
galardonado con otras distinciones está
próximo a lanzar su nuevo disco La
Escalona nunca se había grabado así una
producción moderna que expone las
conexiones Sonoras que fueron
protagonistas en la revolución de la
música de Colombia así llegamos al final
de este informativo aquí en France 24
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía
quédense con nosotros que volvemos en
breve
[Música]